[Music]
so a guy dies
okay how
is that what you're going to say
i think the beginning of a poem i won't
tell you
i want clues
a bird drowns oh no and the rainbows
form no oh it's [ __ ]
that's how they think about this he's a
he's an elderly man
so how did he die fell down the stairs
like a [ __ ] bag of sticks
is that a real expression
hi in his sleep because he's a geezer no
he died from covid he was having sex and
he died no um that would be the sickest
way to go not for her or him but yeah
his duvet top three maybe no he died
during a
crucifixion reenactment but the cross
[ __ ] went you're close but no he
choked on his dentures no
his hearing aids exploded is there a
reenactment at all he had a heart attack
while he was playing santa claus you're
all wrong
okay
civil war maybe he was flying an
airplane no he got [ __ ] to death by a
bunch of dudes in a gang bang oh my god
for real actually that's sad
is he a senior citizen
is that really the thing yeah he got
passed around like a piece of meat damn
i [ __ ] to death
are you [ __ ] serious dude they
wouldn't let up
i know you wouldn't let up
i don't know if you're serious it says
right shut up it sounds like crazy it
smells like [ __ ] but no so it was
outside
that's what it sounds like is this a sex
crime or was it was it like name is
garde okay guardia was found
having been [ __ ] to death wait guardia
had all these [ __ ] sound like corner
terms
guard a had an orgy it's a public
statement it says that the group of
offenders
had a case of sugar-free red bull
oh dude
no way they wouldn't stop going in [ __ ]
each other to death all right
they didn't stop it because they didn't
stop going in on him he just couldn't
pull through no chance yeah
the [ __ ] wait how old is this dude like
81. he's 70 years old 70. yeah i'm still
waiting for that moment where he's like
no
it was consensual to a point no no no it
was a bizarre incident
where a bunch of people yeah a bunch of
people dragged him
into this environment and then yeah real
article jack in the box has a new
sandwich
what the [ __ ] are these no so so uh
people don't know why he died natural
causes probably
but there's a sad incident where
um two people who found him dead
dragged him into a post office to
collect his pension
oh wait so they did one of those weekend
at bernie [ __ ] where they put them on a
dolly and they're like yo man
and then like he's like that might be
worse than yeah [ __ ] somebody's a
death man dude i know dude if you just
died in mid-coitus you know that's very
different than this so they so they
wheel-barreled them yeah they did that's
so wrong did they go to jail for that
wait how how do you get money out of the
post office how does that no so what you
do is well at the post office where you
call it's where you collect the pensions
you send it it is america no no no no
this this is in ireland in ireland i
don't know you get the pensions at the
post office i thought you they they
bring it to your door
[ __ ] thing called an envelope so old
people gotta leave the house every time
and collect the pensions
this is some [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] man
well they don't have postal guys that
deliver checks and [ __ ] so the best part
is that
you have to be present for it
and then um
they propped him up against the counter
and told steph that he was here and
asked the pension did they prop him up
did they prop him up and then they
[ __ ] played his [ __ ]
[Music]
man
yeah give me my attention you filthy
animal
it's from the 90s
one to ten
but it's [ __ ] in ireland so they're
like
oh my gosh oh he sounds weird he doesn't
sound like us it's just a little bit
hard huh a little bit hard give me my
pot of gold
he sounds like an american looks like a
real gang break better manner
another one [ __ ] her death oh my
goodness another one placed the dust
that's happening i'm not here in dublin
what happened to my dubliners
must have been a case of sugar free red
bull
it's what motivates them it's crazy so
yes they're looking into you know
whether any criminal offense was carried
out obviously yes it was but
they're looking into it they have to
make sure that they can
happen yeah
um but yeah they
they the men come in and they say they
want to collect uh a pension for a
relative and then they go hey this
person has to be here for that and then
the boys are like
they both look they don't
come let's just let's do this together
so it says
staff explained the person had to be
present for that and the boys go
are you up do you have to do straight
faces
the boys go
oh you're thinking what i'm thinking are
you thinking what i'm thinking
it should be a new marshmallow and the
lucky charm
[Laughter]
let's taste the rainbow so then they
they they brought him back there
brought him up against the counter and
then ask the same question
can we get the pension were they like
what the [ __ ] he's a dead man he's all
blue and [ __ ]
just rigor mortis
they said it was the weight of
equivalent of holding a sack of four
potatoes of four sacks of potatoes
just keeping him holding it all over
yeah yeah he's just [ __ ] wobbling
he's in the middle dude did they try to
make him look alive
or were they like
he was dead like this
okay we're ready for the pension now
we're ready to go you know
just [ __ ] put some shades on him
hey
draw eyes on his eyelids it's covered
they have [ __ ] face masks oh yeah see
what's it
jesus that's so ridiculous
that is [ __ ] wild dude
they just dragged this ass out you know
there's a lot of senior crimes like that
where um
they keep the dead peop the dead old
folks inside of the house when someone
finds out and then they start they keep
collecting their [ __ ] money oh yeah
yeah
free retirement free yeah
it's a pretty sick way a lot of them
yeah they just don't tell the government
when they die it's happening right now
yeah
dude there's a lot of elder abuse cases
though where like you know if if you're
like a frail older woman or like man or
whatever and you're like incontinent
kind of but then somebody is the
executor of your estate did you say
incontinent incontinent yeah like where
you can't not [ __ ] yeah oh and you have
to it's like it's up to your bowels and
not you
but yeah there's somebody who's like the
um the person who like administers your
estate and they have control and so like
they can write checks for you oh yeah
that's true all kinds of [ __ ] for you
it's like what happened with brittany
right so yeah free brittany was like
exactly that kind of [ __ ]
so people have a lot of beef with this
kind of practice yeah not even with dead
elders but like people that are just old
and then they'll be like don't worry
i'll take care of everything for you or
not even they don't have relatives or
whatever they they become power attorney
they they can [ __ ]
that's like what happens at the care
homes yeah when they're like that's some
of the nurses or whatever they just jack
your [ __ ] they just start jacking up
exactly yeah
it's wild man that's really [ __ ] up
dude elder crime is like a huge it's a
huge one dude look at the asian hate
[ __ ] it's all elder crime it's all elder
kind there's not even one person who's
not older in the videos it blows my mind
how many people just want to beat the
[ __ ] out of a grandma or grandpa yeah
that's insane when i see them it's like
it's like a child or like a duck like i
don't look at a duck and want to choke
the [ __ ] out of it
you just want to eat it but it's easy
prey i guess 20 favorite foods they
don't want a challenge especially if you
see like an old asian duck
oh yeah that looks
pecking hey queen duck don't want to be
gendered oh yeah of course of course
yeah that sucks are there pig pancake
ducks i shouldn't ask you i'm sorry i
mean are there pecking ducks before
they're i don't know cookies
i shouldn't ask a group of dancers this
question pre-king duck i [ __ ] up
do you think do you think
do you think maybe people are like uh
who who assault elders
they got [ __ ] up in their head because
they're gonna assault somebody anyway so
then they're actually thinking that's
like the least damaged cause because if
you assault an elder it's like they've
already lived life and they're being
empathetic towards they're not logical
who's going to hit me back
the jury doesn't give a [ __ ] if you're
watching it get knocked out it doesn't
even look premeditated it's like an
immediate attack it looks like a [ __ ]
mountain lion and a bunny like you'll
see a dude just with his headphones on
just dancing or like listening to music
and it just
it's like a second they just go straight
without even thinking twice you ever see
those like released cam footages of like
a nursing home and like the people that
work there just like stealing money from
all the people
it's like really common and they know
how to like hurt them and like they'll
they'll be very negligent so they'll
fall off the bed and be like yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] or they won't like
clean their like uh like diapers
sometimes or yeah they're poop or they
can give them pills they have bed sores
make them pass out
take the [ __ ] all the time they don't
turn them like there's all these there's
always cases like that especially
nursing on themselves yeah they can't
even like articulate what's happening
and the relatives don't even come that
much
right that's why they know and they know
if you if you if you become a parent
right you better be [ __ ] dope to your
kids
because that's probably going to be my
dad alone in a [ __ ] nursing home with
nobody visiting him
and it's like a lot of these people [ __ ]
what happened to where your parents were
your own kids don't want to [ __ ]
visit your ass can i ask you this
insensitive question what would you have
to do to get you to visit him in the in
the nursing home like at this point to
make up for lost time
it's a good question if is his mind gone
uh no no like for reparation yeah what
are you gonna do
how would you have to turn the car
backwards to me
what he solves the afghanistan conflict
somehow like what is he going to do
ukraine and russia are a buddy i think
he has to one
um at least recognize the things that
he's done
because oh you weren't here but i did a
whole video where um i had a last talk
with him recently and he um i [ __ ]
blew up on him because he was trying to
evangelize me and try to preach the word
of god and i'm like you [ __ ]
hypocrite like one of the reasons why i
don't go to church anymore is used to
beat my ass and said when i said i had
too much jesus in my life so i'm like i
felt the violence of god through you and
he goes i never hit you that's [ __ ]
crazy
so then he gas lit me on all the and i
was like dude i got beat multiple times
he goes me i'm not that's that's a
different person like i never beat
anybody in my life i'm a peaceful person
by a random asian guy right that he
literally said that he's like it sounds
like you got beat by someone else
someone else and i'm like what other
adult would hit me he's like don't
asians look very similar
don't we all look alike
like ditching out that way he's like oh
my gosh
shows a picture of his brother he's like
save the crazy he's like come on your
uncle yeah he's like it must have been
you must be [ __ ] with your memory man
that's [ __ ] he's crazy right
so straight narcissist psychopath right
to try to pass that off is not like all
right i was like you [ __ ] think about
this and don't call me back until
you you know you think this through
because i was like even if you don't
remember i was like there has to be an
ounce of guilt or or feelings about it
and he goes how can you blame a man that
doesn't remember that's what you oh wow
that's too fast that's too fast yeah and
i said okay well you could think about
it or else we're not gonna talk and
you're not gonna have any communication
with me and then he goes okay i'll think
about it
calls you back still don't remember man
you